but this is the thing about investing
gambling all this stuff just whatever
you want to call it right the mental in
emotional game
the endurance that you gotta have it's
preparing yourself
um for all of that like I'm a lifelong
player of the game you could lose
battles but like at the end of the day
when you leave that's when you lose the
war
[Music]
so
our boy dokwon
was arrested in Montenegro for false
documents we can't say our boy that's
your boy bro wait you think do you think
do you think they're snatching them up
or do you think there was some wrong
doing because I I have a bone to pick
with this guy dude you guys won't pick
with who with dokon Mr doe what's your
what's your bone go for it you made a
weak ass product let her rip [__] I
don't know anything about crypto okay
but I was invested in Tara Luna and this
guy [__] me maybe potentially maybe
I can swap my money back though Where's
My Money doll yeah yeah so my initial
investment dude a 15 15 15 15
17 I'm gonna keep that close to my chest
dude uh yeah it's it's a it's a toughie
so our boy and every single person in
this room's boy
we have a special connection with this
man yeah I'll say um
so they got him for traveling on a fake
passport in Montenegro which is a
country in the Balkans it's like right
by Kosovo which maybe you know about
because the United States has been
heavily involved in that region since
the 90s
so you probably don't know about it cool
so what what was he doing out there like
um because I thought he was in Korea
Singapore all those things like fleeing
or some [__] because he's trying to get
caught by the cops or something so there
he is he is wanted in South Korea and
apparently the United States is
interested in extraditing him as well
um but I don't know about formal charges
who gets first dibs so he that's why he
has a fake passwords you can try to like
you know sneak sneak around sneak around
sneak around
um if he was traveling with with fake
Indonesian or a fake Costa Rican
passport they look at them they're like
you don't look Latino yeah and he
started speaking Spanish to him and he
goes
see
and that's all he knew how to say how do
they catch him that's crazy I don't know
it just says that he was using Ford's
personal documents so probably that was
a red flag and then they picked him up
from that
um and they're he's facing trial
currently for forged personal documents
not for anything else like a lot of
people are kind of taking this news and
running with it going like they got him
for fraud and all this stuff and stuff
nothing's been proven yeah we don't know
anything really
um we just know they got him for forged
personal documents obviously the idea
that maybe he's running from something
could say could tell you a story yeah
it's not a good look not a good look
plus it got super fat did he he did you
think he's stress eating he's stressed
out from all the lies dude where'd he
get all those extra calories from do the
stress eating or uh he's just eating
good oh yeah [__] God damn it yeah he's
like [__] I got a billion Lobster extra
butter please thank you he better not be
yeah he better not be he better be
stressed eating dude if I find a
pleasure eating calories I'm gonna be
pissed I thought he kept the terraform
Labs together they were working on a
comeback terraform Maps is still is
still a thing yeah it's still out the
steak and rewards to this day my boy
that's a fact
um chair's not dead hashtag terror's not
dead but you know what who cares really
like it's just about you know for me
it's about moving on what does the
market need like I don't know about Tara
as a solution particularly to what the
market needs right now because I looked
at Tara's potentially like okay you know
we need things to kind of solve the
financial issue that you have in crypto
where you can't really use crypto as
money very well and Tara was kind of
helping to do that for a lot of people
um until we got exploded so then you
know after we got exploded it turns out
like it's not very good that's hip-hop
for exploded oh [__] yeah I think that's
just Steve bro that's just Steve like
that Steve for exploded yeah let's see
for hip-hop what's the whole thing right
now though what's the whole Community
talking about like
well there's a there's a fracture here
right so like there's people who are
just like and you know you never know
what people are going through so some
people hella people lost money right
hella people are like yo I believe in
the mission of crypto matter the [__]
what right and then there's hella people
who are like hey I think dokwon's a
scapegoat I think that it was an attack
from maybe Alameda research who's been
tied to what just happened with SPF I
mean
it clearly was an attack it wasn't I
mean you know like
he withdrew
withdrew like it was a clear it got
depaked from an attack yeah it was it
was attacked but we don't necessarily
know exactly where the attack the vector
of attack came from it could have been
Insider the liquidity was pulled from
um
um Luna from UST by dokwon we don't know
yeah that's true that's the thing and
you can see it on the blockchain right
you can see addresses and all that stuff
but we don't know exactly who owns what
I could literally create a crypto
address right now so ultimately
ultimately when it comes to this entire
Saga you know there's still just so much
that has to happen but everyone wants to
cast judgment and we just don't know
enough so you could look at all the
terraform Labs addresses right and see
money being moved around because they're
trying to move money around to back UST
with Bitcoin at the time they're turning
back with like 3.5 billion dollars of
Bitcoin
um that was hopefully gonna make up for
you know
any kind of issue that could have
happened which happened the year prior
to that if you remember in May of a year
before Tara died there was an issue with
UST maintaining the Peg and the biggest
criticism from that was hey we need more
reserves what is it back and then they
decided to back it by Bitcoin which also
became the Achilles heel yeah it was
because brilliant concept he told
everybody what he was going to do and
then he he dared billionaires he
actually said billionaires following me
try to [__] destroy us because it was
just it was just like a real cocky
moment real hubris cocky mom yeah the
downfall is is a dokwon viewed in the
same light as sfb or no are they like
villains I would say so as far as writ
large in the crypto community
a part of the whole villains of crypto
yeah for now yeah yeah we'll see what
happens too I I'm not carrying water for
the guy I literally just don't know
anything I do think though his bravado
and all that was interesting but also
attracted way too much attention
unnecessary attention why dare people to
destroy your project stay low-key dude
it's not just you who dies if your
project dies right yeah be the unsung
hero that just keeps it going keep your
head down keep focused you know but
there was like he was the sun hero
almost there but there were like Wagers
that he was putting on he's like he said
I'll take this bet yeah fine I'll bet
you this you know what I mean it came
out there he's talking about a guy who
bet him he was like I'll bet I bet you a
million dollars it turned to more than
that by the way
um that Tara will be below like 20 bucks
by this time next year and dope one's
like I'll take that [__] bet you
[__] idiot and you lost it you lost
it just put that in escrow basically
like a smart contract and then that was
paid out when pair of dropped in price
pretty quickly I know you said that um
you don't really there's not enough
information out but do you have a
prediction of how this is going to
unfold like based on what you've seen so
far and kind of the patterns of
everything uh it's really just one of
those things where I do believe that UST
was attacked by some entity yeah but was
dokwon part of it so so we'll see
because I don't know like it could have
been Alameda worked with dokwan and put
some money on it right now you think he
was also also though like when you think
about it too it's like even if it was
attacked regardless of how even if it
was [__] evil intention
at the end of the day it's still
pointing out a giant flaw in it you know
what I mean so like exactly that's just
kind of part of any like early adoption
development or anything if you really
wanted something that actually work out
you're gonna get [__] attacked at
every corner of every flaw until it's
proven that it can work you know even
when it worked like you know I
I people get pissed sometimes about this
in the Terry Community but the night
that it really died and then I was doing
crypto Corner live about it I was just
saying hey credit to the attackers like
they proved of vulnerability and they
explorted the [__] out of it and they're
making money off of it and that's how
this works sometimes like in a
decentralized environment where you're
trying to prove that you can be
decentralized money you need to be able
to sustain attacks multiple attacks from
multiple vectors like you need to be
able to prove yourself and it was almost
like war games but we all got caught in
a crossfire and the test is still
happening like people like the thing I
don't like about crypto is how
Evangelical and married they become to
their coin absolutely and then as I wear
blue merch up and down
[Laughter]
excited about coins I might like talk
great about it but I'm not the I mean
I'm not like in the same cap as like
people who are like they live and die by
a certain coin because to me that's just
way too devout to me it and I always say
this to my crypto Corners I'm like look
yes uh it's ironic that I'm sitting here
wearing blue merch and I have a woman
down and all this [__] but like
ultimately at the end of the day this is
the coin that I am going to Slit the
neck of to feed my family right like I
am going like I'm raising it like a
little cattle right and then one day
when the time comes and I made enough
money off of it and it's got enough meat
on it I'm I need to cook right and
that's just how it works and that
doesn't mean the project will be
unviable by then or anything like that I
I don't anticipate any of that I
anticipate growth for it but eventually
dude you have to pay yourself for for
being right about something and you know
as much as Luna died we were [__]
dead on the whole run up multiples out
of our [__] but you got to pay
yourself for the work too I didn't do
that I didn't pay myself for the word me
neither I paid myself a little bit yeah
yeah but I actually came up with profit
but
yeah I mean we left way more on the
table and that's what always it haunts
you a little bit a lot more on it life
changing on the table but there's always
the next move [__] but always
but this is the thing about investing
gambling all this stuff just whatever
you want to call it right the mental and
emotional game
the endurance that you've got to have
it's preparing yourself
um for all of that like I'm a lifelong
player of the game you could lose
battles but like at the end of the day
when you leave that's when you lose the
war so I'm still in it baby like I'm
still like here to fight another day and
it seems like the war is really really
losing is it though we're still in it
crypto hey as [__] on this crypto is I
know you're kidding but it's [__] on as
crypto is trillion dollar market cap
right like a trillion dollar industry
like just Clowning it all you want
[__] and crypto haters out
there it's worth a trillion dollars out
there and even the top 100 right you go
all the way down the list and coins that
are like number 99 are worth like 300
million like just chill out a little bit
I know that like your your uncle thinks
crypto sucks and like he's a super
smartie but like if you if you
understand why this stuff has economic
viability why having an independent
economy from the economy that kills us
already
um is maybe attractive to a lot of
people out there you know that's that's
the purpose that's kind of the mission
statement that's the hope I'm gonna
start investing in the Yuan honestly it
seems like you might not be going on a
bet you're gonna get out of USD yeah I
am I don't know dude I might buy a
couple of you go on yeah
my USD right now for 0.02 percent of my
savings account
let's go
[Music]